bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78 et
radio sensations pour un nouveau débat
dans le cadre du premier tour des
élections municipales de 2020 un scrutin
qui se déroulera le 15 mars prochain
nous recevons aujourd'hui les candidats
en lice sur la commune de montigny le
bretonneux trois listes sont déclarés au
9 février
montigny ensemble porté par laura
merckaert montini solidarité 2020 mené
par pierre déjean alternative innovante
est écologique et solidaire avec comme
tête de liste viviane gasc bonjour à
tous les trois amis bonjour au cours de
ce débat le temps de parole sera
chronométré pour assurer une égalité
entre vous pour lancer un premier tour
de table avec cette question pourquoi
les électeurs devraient vous choisir et
nous débutons avec vous pierre déjean
c'est l'ordre qui a été décidé par
tirage au sort tout comme les places sur
ce plateau faire des gens vous mener une
liste ancré à gauche a notamment avec
des membres du parti socialiste et des
mouvements citoyens de gauche vous êtes
vous même engagé au sein du parti de
gauche
vous avez aussi été conseiller municipal
d'opposition lors du précédent mandat
rien d'officiel mais vous aurez sûrement
le soutien d'europe écologie les verts
alors pourquoi vous les inimitables
proposés pour vous très bien de juste
une petite occasion je n'étais pas dans
l'opposition mais dans la minorité et je
tiens à cette différence parce que ça a
une signification tout à fait différente
alors pourquoi est ce que les ailiers
montain devrait s'engager sur notre
liste
et bien justement parce que nous ne
réclamons très clairement de toutes les
valeurs de gauche et que pour nous ça a
une signification les partis politiques
ont connu d'ions quelques errements
parfois c'est dommage nous le déplorons
tous c'est largement dû à un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont été au
moment de des responsabilités mais pour
nous ça ne change pas les valeurs nous
et
une caractéristique justement de notre
collectif c'est qu'il regroupe tout
l'arc de la gauche
à peu près tout l'art de la gauche et
sans que nous mettions en avant les
parties justement à cause de cela et
nous avons aussi des des militants
associatifs comme attaque par exemple
mais nous avons aussi des militants ou
sur des causes humanitaires humaniste ou
du bien-être animal
si nous recouvrons tout là tout l'art de
dire qui mais le l'humain et le vivant
au coeur de notre projet laura merckaert
vous vous avez été directeur de cabinet
de plusieurs maires iny montant
aujourd'hui vous présenter avec des élus
de la majorité actuelle alors à 50%
renouveler vous des forces de droite et
du centre vous avez reçu le soutien du
modem de l'udps y ait des républicains
alors pourquoi lésigny montant devrait
voter pour vous le 15 mars prochain
alors effectivement je vais conduire la
liste montigny ensemble je tiens à
rendre hommage tout d'abord à la liste
actuelle puisque le travail est encore
en cours et ils ont on a pu le présenter
aux habitants par le biais du bilan
proposé un programme très ambitieux sur
toute la durée de ce mandat qui a été
porté par jean hugo et précédemment par
un michel laugier qui s'étaient
présentés en 2014 avec un programme très
ambitieux donc un bel hommage à ces
personnes qui ont vraiment travaille
énormément
effectivement aujourd'hui moi j'arrive
avec cette expérience de 19 ans en tant
que directeur de cabinet aux côtés de
d'abord nicolas bour qu'une chaîne logis
et j'en ai courbot ces dernières années
19 ans de traits de travail de gestion
de dossiers mais aussi par mon
tempérament d'accompagnement des
habitants puisque j'ai toujours été au
cours de ses 19 ans sur le terrain aux
côtés des associations aux côtés des
amicales de locataires des conseils de
quartier et donc c'est fort de cette
expérience à la fois des dossiers mais
aussi de la connaissance des habitants
que je me présente à eux
vous l'avez dit j'ai une liste qui sera
renouvelée à 50 % c'est à dire que j'ai
des personnes avec moi qui sont
expérimentés qui ont déjà l'habitude de
gérer soi des délégations soient des
conseils de quartier et c'est important
je trouve et en même temps j'ai 50 % de
personnes qui arrivent
essentiellement des personnes jeunes qui
sont issus de tous les quartiers
qui représente toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles des personnes qui
viennent du milieu associatif des
conseils de quartier dont des gens qui
sont engagés déjà bénévolement pour la
ville depuis plusieurs années et c'est
une liste ouverte je peux le préciser
pour toutes ces personnes que j'ai fait
rentrer dans l'équipe je n'ai demandé à
aucune quel était leur opinion politique
ce n'est pas mon sujet ce qui
m'intéressait c'était ce qu'elle avait
proposé pendant des années sur la ville
pour les habitants merci vivien gas que
vous êtes actuellement conseiller
municipal d'opposition ancien membre du
parti socialiste un parti que vous avez
quittez il y a deux ans je crois vous
engager dans cette campagne avec une
liste sans étiquette politique pas
partisane une démarche qualifiée de
citoyenne et participative alors
pourquoi les habitants continuent pour
toni devrait voter pour vous
effectivement je représente un collectif
citoyen du nom de n donc alternative
iny monteyne écologique et solidaire ce
collectif est composé de personnes qui
sont engagés voire très engagés dans des
associations de la ville où des
associations nationales des gens qui ont
qui ont envie de contribuer des citoyens
qui ont envie de contribuer à la vie de
la cité
c'est un exemple un ensemble très très
mixte très collectif qui se retrouve
dans quelques valeurs fortes
ça c'est important c'est pas parce qu'on
est à partisans que on ne retrouve pas
dans un certain nombre de valeurs
donc l'attention portée aux générations
futures et à la préservation de la
planète
l'accueil de la différence la solidarité
et puis la responsabilité citoyenne pour
ne citer que celles ci
depuis le mois de septembre nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des habitants de la
ville de montigny
nous avons échangé avec eux nous avons
recueilli leurs propositions leurs
attentes leurs critiques aussi du
travail réalisé par la municipalité
sortante de façon à pouvoir commencer à
écrire un programme et je crois qu'on a
beaucoup intéressé par une posture qui a
été constructive ouverte et est
caractéristique caractéristiques uniques
dans cette campagne
affranchi de tout parti politique tout
le monde va vous dire je ne suis pas je
remets je ne représente pas tel ou tel
parti politique pour autant comme on
peut le constater avec monsieur maire
guerrière qui revendique eu l'étiquette
de droite des républicains par exemple
pour ne citer que celui ci on est nous
dans une dans une posture tout à fait
tout à fait différente donc on a tenu
quatre assemblées citoyennes depuis le
mois de novembre sur fort de ces de ces
constats initiaux qui nous ont permis de
rédiger un manifeste d'élaborer un
programme de hiérarchiser des
propositions de constituer la liste dans
des assemblées citoyennes ouverte et
participative de désigner notre binôme
tête de liste puisque c'est bien d'un
binôme qu'il s'agit avec caroline de ce
chaos
et puis d'organiser aussi notre campagne
de deux façons ouverte
petite touche finale la rédaction d'une
charte éthique dont on aura peut-être
l'occasion de parler plus tard donc
voilà nous sommes prêts et c'est une
équipe qui se mobilisent et pas un homme
seul
merci jean gasc voilà pour ce premier
tour de table on voit les temps de
parole sa fiche est donc un peu d'avancé
pour vivien gasc pierre déjean vous
avaient le plus de retard on aura le
temps de bien sûr de rééquilibrer sous
ces temps de parole mais avant d'aborder
les différentes thématiques sur la sur
ce débat je vous propose de regarder ce
sujet un tour d'horizon des principaux
enjeux sur la commune de montigny le
bretonneux un reportage de marie lehn
iapichino la concertation a débuté cet
été pour la réhabilitation de l'hyper
centre de saint quentin en yvelines
si le projet est piloté par la
communauté d'agglomération le territoire
concerne bien montigny le bretonneux
l'objectif étant de moderniser ce
quartier bâti dans les années 1980
qu'ils répondent aux problématiques
d'usagers de transports et de nature en
ville d'aujourd'hui la nature et
l'environnement c'est justement l'un des
enjeux de ces élections municipales
montigny le bretonneux aspire à réaliser
sa transition écologique la commune
n'échappe pas au contexte démographique
général et doit faire face à une
population vieillissante
un phénomène accentué par un coût du
logement élevé les jeunes familles et
ninten peinent à accéder à la propriété
et quittent la ville un mange dedans
plus fort que montigny le bretonneux
accueille de nombreux sièges
d'entreprises
comme récemment bmw dans le quartier du
pas du lac et on les salariés sont en
pleine installation dans ses nouveaux
locaux des constructions de logements
dont des logements sociaux font
justement partie de plusieurs chantiers
communaux en cours celui du forum des
arts charles aznavour à la place de
l'ancien collège bergson livraison
prévue en avril 2021 mais également la
réfection du club le village fermé en
décembre dernier pour douze mois de
travaux
55 à 60 logements font partie du projet
mais l'événement dont la nouvelle
municipalité aura à s'emparer ce sont
bien sûr les jeux olympiques de 2024
le vélodrome nationale accueillera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et l'île
de loisirs sell de bmx ont entendu dans
ce sujet l'un des sujets importants et
d'actualité pour montigny le bretonneux
c'est la réhabilitation de l'hyper
centre
un quartier datant des années 80 c'est
le secteur autour de la gare du théâtre
national et de l'espace commercial
plusieurs entreprises sont installées
aussi et des logements ont été
construits dans ce contexte des ateliers
des changes ont été organisées c'est un
dossier piloté par saint quentin en
yvelines mais dont montini participe
activement dessus
par conséquent si vous êtes élu maire
pierre déjean va commencer par vous
puisque je vais vous êtes en retard sur
le temps de parole comment agir et vous
sur ce dossier écoutez cette cette
opération effectivement qui est initié
par la communauté d'agglomération parce
que c'est de son domaine de compétence
et ça permet effectivement de faire tout
de suite le lien entre la commune et la
communauté d'agglomération qui verront à
qui verra les délégués communautaires et
lure même temps que les conseils
municipaux c'est important parce que les
acteurs environ deux listes
effectivement sur le même bulletin
nous avons un certain nombre de
le colistier qui participent
effectivement qui se sont inscrits qui
participe aux travaux aux travaux de la
commission et je dirais que nous vous
voyons une zone qui est entièrement
couverte par le béton et c'est peut-être
un dommage dommage il faudrait aérer un
peu et mettre un peu plus de l'espace
public et vert ceci étant dit c'est un
projet à long terme qui va durer 10 ans
15 ans peut-être donc bien au delà de du
mandat qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui et
nous sommes parfois un peu un peu
inquiète en tout cas on se pose des
questions
parce que on a au moins deux éléments
importants comme les meubles
l'international et puis le la poste qui
sont déjà en travaux presque terminée
pour pour l'un et donc qui fait qu'ils
font partie de cette vous appelez
l'hyper centre et jeux pour un peu la
question qu'est ce qui va devenir du
reste est ce que la commission qui est
en place n'est pas une caution pour
faire croire à une pseudo démocratie ou
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
cache derrière vous savez que monsieur
fourgous qui est président de la
communauté d'agglo a eu l'idée
actuellement génial de construire une
tour plus haute que la tour montparnasse
dans ce quartier où j'aborde de ce
quartier un tour que nous avons réduit
en poussière par un communiqué de presse
au mois d'août c'est bien ce qui prouve
aussi notre efficacité et de ce côté là
je dirais que
sur vaud l'engagement on se demande
vraiment s'il n'y a pas quelque chose
derrière de cachet et en particulier sur
le devenir de ce qu'est ce que vous
comment vous voyez cette hyper tendus
alors c'est quelque chose qui pas facile
parce que justement il interrompt une
densité de béton déjà de très
importantes mais ça veut dire que si on
met
si on veut mettre un peu de bide of la
supprimer des bâtiments mais ce n'est
pas que cela parce qu'il ya aussi tous
les abords il ya la place georges
pompidou il ya la venue du centre
et puis d'autres d'autres voies de
circulation que là on va pouvoir ménager
pour les piétons pour les cyclistes et
met un peu peur des lieux de promenade
ou agréable vous avez pris beaucoup
d'avancé merci laurent je vous laisse
répondre parce que des gens vous
interpelle le défaut de démocratie dans
les concertations est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer justement le principe des
concertations qui sont mis en place
et puis vous la vision que vous
souhaiter pour cette hyper centre de
mesures bien sûr sur la sur la façon
dont nous avons souhaité impliquer les
citoyens
lorsque nous avons commencé à travailler
sur ce sujet avec la communauté
d'agglomération l'initiative
effectivement de lancer une concertation
a été porté par l'agglomération parce
que depuis des années nous travaillons
sur tous les sujets qui touchent à
l'hyper centre et c'est assez compliqué
de progresser sur ce sujet parce que on
est sur un système extrêmement complexe
avec des copropriétés la venue du centre
tous les habitants ne le savent pas
forcément mais c'est une voie qui est
privé la servitude de passage public
mais c'est une voie privée quand on
prend la place pompidou le bitume
appartient est géré par la communauté
d'agglomération mais le parking lui
appartient à la nasl qui gère le centre
commercial
donc c'est compliqué de faire avancer
tout ça en même temps parce que multi
investisseurs multipropriétaires donc la
communauté d'agglomération a proposé un
plan avec une concertation est derrière
que l'on puisse s'établir à un schéma
d'aménagement qui effectivement comme
dit monsieur des gens effective sera
s'échelonnera sur des années parce que
c'est très complexe et très long et que
ça représentera des investissements
coûteux et la communauté d'agglomération
a souhaité nous demander quelle forme de
concertation nous souhaitions avoir sur
le sujet j'ai donc demandé à la rentrée
lorsque nous avons travaillé là dessus à
ce que les habitants puissent être
sollicités et impliqué dès le départ sur
cette concertation nous avons souhaité
cela pour une raison très simple c'est
que c'est à la fois un quartier
d'affaires à la fois un quartier
étudiant un quartier commerçant mais
c'est avant tout un quartier
d'habitation et comme on part sur des
aménagements qui comme ce qui existe
toujours
lui seront réalisés pour au moins une
trentaine d'années il était vraiment
indispensable que les personnes puissent
être impliqués et c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité organiser d'abord la balade
urbaine où plus de 60 personnes sont
venues et puis ensuite de développer des
ateliers qui permettent aux gens à la
fois de s'exprimer sur sur leur vision
du quartier mais aussi sur ce qu'il
souhaite y mettre ce qu'il souhaite y
voir et l'engagement pris avec la
communauté d'agglomération est ce que
les habitants soit associé jusqu'au
choix des projets qui seront présentés
et qui pourront ensuite se décliner sur
le saut sur le territoire dans la vision
qu'on en a nous aujourd'hui par rapport
à tout cela
effectivement c'est un quartier qui est
très minéral c'était sa conception à
l'époque qui laisse énormément de place
à la voiture
ce que nous souhaitons non non c'est
avoir un quartier qui soit au contraire
beaucoup plus piétonnier parmi les idées
comme ça qu'ils que nous avons pu
travailler qui ont été avancées par les
habitants il y a entre autres sur la
nuit du centre quand on regarde vers le
vert le théâtre de pouvoir étendre sur
ce sujet au premier rang s'est formée à
l'est dit je vous en prie merci donc
cessé d'étendre le trottoir jusqu'à
l'endroit vous avez les voitures garées
au milieu pour avoir un vrai véritable
espace qui soit accueillant pour les
piétons on puisse mettre des terrasses
de café mettre des food truck redonner
de la vie à cet espace inciter les gens
à s'y retrouver puisque c'est notre
coeur de ville un seul coeur de saint
quentin mais c'est le coeur de ville de
montigny merci donc on a compris un
piétonniser vous vivien gasc comment
vous voyez ce quartier comment vous
voyez l'évolution de l'hyper centre de
montigny-le-bretonneux
avant de répondre précisément à votre
question je me permet quand même de
sourire
en réponse à ce que dit monsieur merker
parce que quand monsieur monsieur
mercader récupère cette démarche de
concertation de l'agglomération que nous
trouvons d'ailleurs tout à fait
intéressante et à laquelle nous
participons à un carreau 10 k o a
participé aux différentes réunions qui
ont été organisées
je pense qu'il faut à mon avis il faut
pas récupérer ce type de démarche
monsieur merker la ville n'a pas montré
des grandes capacités des grands talents
dans sa capacité à concerter les
habitants sur montigny
on l'a vu par exemple pour le
conservatoire
le forum des arts et
avec du coup du rattrapage en
catastrophe d'oubli sur le stationnement
qui se font d'ailleurs de manière
catastrophique là aussi on va le voir
aussi pour pour le secteur de la place
malraux et de la maison de quartier
malraux une simple réunion d'information
ne constitue pas une concertation
ça c'était juste une petite introduction
sur ce quartier on se dit que montier la
ville centre d'une agglomération de 230
mille habitants et est donc on parle là
du centre ville de la ville centre d'une
agglomération de 230 mille habitants il
va falloir le devenir de cette hyper
centre je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
éléments je vais pas revenir sur ses
orientations générales que je partage
pour le coup il faut effectivement
verdir il faut rendre plus + pétonnet
piétonnier ce secteur il faut peut-être
aussi un peu choisir les activités qui
ce qui s'installe parce que excusez moi
mais au lieu de jouer au fusil en
réalité virtuelle comme c'est le cas
maintenant sur sur skywest on peut faire
la place pour une autre type de
d'économie une économie circulaire une
économie sociale et solidaire et ce
serait beaucoup plus intéressant de
d'affiché cela au coeur de notre de
notre territoire
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé économie 1
depuis le début ce débat c'est pas
tellement prévu à l'ordre du jour est
pour nous c'est important de pouvoir en
parler
voilà donc tous là par contre petite
chose importante quand même tout ça doit
se faire en articulation bonne
articulation avec le reste du territoire
et notamment les centres commerciaux de
quartier qui n'ont pas fait l'objet de
la même attention particulière de la
municipalité sortante ces dernières
années et sur lesquelles il faut
intervenir centre commercial de la
sourderie le centre commercial du manet
sont des secteurs sur lesquels on a des
intentions des projets et sur lesquelles
il faut il faut travailler
voilà c'est important parfait on va
changer de thématiques on voit justement
parlé d'accès au logement scellier à ce
dossier de l'hyper centre parce que
comme je l'aï indiqué il y à des
logements dans cette zone alors une
thématique assez large
vous voulez aborder la question des
logements sociaux avec la loi sru qui
oblige les communes à avoir 25 % de
logements sociaux dans la ville il ya la
question de l'accession à la propriété
et la problématique de l'accueil des
étudiants puisque montigny se situe à
côté d'une université a même une
université avec l'ufr six modèles la fac
de santé quelles sont les actions que
vous allez proposer sur ces sujets on va
commencer avec vous pierre déjean
puisque vous avez un peu de retard
effectivement le problème du logement
est cruciale à montigny girish pas la
même et mba mais victime d'une location
je n'ai pas trouvé
et ça m'a contraint hd mon logement en
ce qui concerne le logement étudiant là
on paye effectivement la carence du
pouvoir en place depuis semble d'année
puisque il était pas question je demande
d'accueillir ces étudiants parce que ces
jeunes c'est ça fait du bruit et avec
l'université même où parlait de simone
veil effectivement mais à côté nous
avons l'université située sur guyancourt
mais vraiment tout à fait aux limites de
montigny que de toute façon fait partie
de l'agglomération où là aussi draine à
son étudiant qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
forcément tout seul le choix de se loger
à bas à bas prix et de ce côté là nous
avons l'intention effectivement de faire
une espèce de bourse en association avec
les associations locales qui dont
certaines s'occupe de cela pour mettre
en relation des personnes qui auraient
un logement au trop grand
parce qu'elles ont vieilli parce que les
enfants sont partis donc des chambres
disponibles et qui pourrait très bien
accueillir chez elle des étudiants qui
eux sont en recherche d'un simplement
d'une chambre était un peu de confort et
en plus ça jouerait également sur un
autre point sur lequel nous sommes
censés de c'est la mixité sociale et
intergénérationnelle sur cette question
de l'accès au logement alors plusieurs
sujets que j'ai évoquées on partage le
constat est cas notamment étaient bien
décrits dans le dans le reportage de
d'un difficulté pour les jeunes
notamment d'accéder au logement que ce
soit les jeunes étudiants sur la
location ou les jeunes familles sur la
propriété de piste puis une troisième
question importante pour nous il faut
construire il faut construire un peu
plus et il ya certains certains secteurs
comme la zone de l'observatoire à
proximité de la gare de trappes sur
lesquels on peut encore construire il
faut s'en occuper
et puis une deuxième piste du logement
intergénérationnel
on pense que
il ya un certain nombre de personnes qui
ont vécu avec leur famille dans leur
dans leur maison et
qui on commençait à vieillir les
familles sont parties il a encore des
grandes maisons et seront pas forcément
envie de les quitter à l'autre côté on
allait les étudiants dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure qui sont à la recherche
de logement de logements papa très cher
peut-être que la ville pourrait proposer
une mise en relation de ses différents
publics là et puis du coup des jeunes
étudiants qui viendraient s'installer
moyennant un loyer modique dans une
chambre avec les dépendances qui vont
bien de des maisons de certaines
personnes qui les accueillerait
volontiers ça s'organise
il faut créer peut-être un outil local
une association de structure quel que
soit son statut
ou alors s'appuyer sur des structures
existantes qu'ils font très très bien
sur d'autres territoires et je voulais
ajouter un point qui me semble assez
important la ville dispose de logements
de logements aujourd'hui qu'elle peut
affecter alors pour dans certains cas
pour des gardiens par exemple c'est
totalement incontestable et parfois
également pour pour d'autres d'autres
personnels il me semble monsieur
merckaert qu'à titre personnel vous avez
occupé pendant quelques années vous nous
direz peut-être combien exactement un
logement de la ville ce qui me semble
important c'est alors précisé c'est
vraiment préciser les conditions
d'attribution de ces logements là et
d'en faire une politique vraiment très
strictes et très rigoureuse pour nous
ces questions de transparence c'est
vraiment très important alors vous allez
réagir par rapport à ce que dit vivien
gasquet vous porter aussi un bilan par
rapport au dernier mandat
la liste que vous portez il ya des
logements qui ont été construits pendant
ce mandat je pense notamment à la alors
l'actuel il est en cours de construction
le forum des arts de charles aznavour
mais aussi il va y avoir des logements
qui vont être construits aussi sur la
rénovation du club le village alors vos
propositions la gestion de ses dossiers
justement du bar d'urbanisation et puis
répondait peut-être un vivien gasconne
oui alors sur effectivement sur montigny
je crois que on a toujours connu une
grue dans le ciel de montigny parce que
depuis toujours on construit à la fois
des équipements publics
et puis des logements et danser l'un
façon dont nous avons pensé depuis
toujours
l'aménagement sur la ville pour les
imminentes à vous le connaissez bien
on a toujours pratiqué une mixité dans
les quartiers c'est à dire que ont fait
à la fois du logement libre du logements
en locatif social et du logement aussi
que l'on propose parfois en accession
sociale
juste une petite chose la mise en
relation des étudiants avec les
personnes âgées ça existe déjà depuis
plusieurs années sur le territoire il ya
ainsi que pour ça il faut pas le faire
une fois ou deux en fait il faut en
faire un système mais c'est un système
de taxis à combien en mesure de
surmonter une moto n'a en fait suggéré
par l'agglomération et vous avez ainsi
est aujourd'hui sans savoir faire la
relation jeunes aquitains sisters
combien il ya de réussite sur
montigny-le-bretonneux combien gérer
versa je ne serai pas pressé je ne
semblait pas vous répondre mais par
contre je sais que le système est dit
donc pour continuer sur les logements
nous avons toujours mis de la mixité
dans les quartiers nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 28% en logements sociaux
ce qui ce que nous avons surtout essayé
développée ces dernières années et que
nous proposons aux habitants pour la
suite
ce sont à la cotco côté du logement en
accession libre on à l'opération du new
wave par exemple un centre ville qui en
est une représentation assez juste on a
trois cages d'escalier dans ce bâtiment
une cage d'escalier en accession libre
une cage d'escalier d'escalier en
locatif social et une cage d'escalier en
locatif intermédiaire le locatif
intermédiaire pour nous est une solution
vraiment intéressante pour les jeunes
car c'est un système où on propose du
logement à 20% en dessous des prix du
marché et surtout pour lequel il y a
nettement moins de contraintes au moment
de la présentation du dossier parce que
c'est souvent ça qui freine les jeunes
c'est que quand il faut présenter un
dossier on vous demande des garanties
tellement importante que les gens ne
peuvent pas donc voilà ce que nous
souhaitons continuer de proposer sur la
ville avec un développement d'urbanisme
désormais mesurer parce que nous avons
une ville qui est quand même très
construit nous avons 40 % espaces verts
sur cette ville et nous souhaitons les
préserver juste une petite pression de
new wave
du coup c'est le bâtiment pour que pour
nos téléspectateurs un niveau
international à place de
l'internet où est situé explo ap / you
la gare tout à fait on va changer de
thématiques et on va parler d'une
préoccupation au niveau national
excusez moi je pense que j'ai posé une
question à monsieur merckaert tout à
l'heure pas comme il s'agit d'un débat
peut-être que ça doit être intéressant
de connaître un peu les candidats voire
bution des logements de la ville se
conclure rapidement 20 secondes en
réponse sur les attributions de sûr
c'est tout simple il y avait auparavant
une possibilité pour le personnel
communal pour une partie du personnel
communal de pouvoir accéder à des
logements de fonction
et puis les lois ont évolué et depuis
maintenant je crois à cinq ans je
n'occupe plus largement fonction sur les
documents privés
merci pour ces explications va passer à
une préoccupation nationale c'est la
transition environnementale
et justement c'est l'une des thématiques
phares de votre programme viviane
gasquet même qui vous réunit tous les
trois vous proposez vraiment des boues
fait des propositions sur cette
thématique la vie vient garçon va
commencer avec vous alors quelles sont
vos propositions sur ce sujet là merci
effectivement pour nous la transition
écologique ce n'est pas une tactique
électorale c'est véritablement un
programme et c'est peut-être la première
grande ligne force de notre de neuf au
programme
j'ai envie de citer trois propositions
qui nous démarque
la première chose c'est nous voulons une
ville basse consommation ça signifie une
mairie exemplaire dansez dansez
consommation c'est rénover les bâtiments
de la ville et pour le coup à ressource
constante on a environ 10 millions
d'euros d'investissement chaque année
nous pouvons mieux allouer les les
moyens de la ville pour faire des
économies d'énergie dans les budgets de
fonctionnement qu'on peut ensuite
réutilisés nous voulons aussi que les
clés bâtiments privés que les
propriétaires qui sont intéressés
puissent être accompagnés pour les
encourager et pour pouvoir rénover plus
vite le parc immobilier de la
delà du territoire deuxième propres de
propositions nous souhaitons que nos
enfants mangent mieux qu'aujourd'hui
nous voulons remplacer le système avec
une entreprise qui fabrique les repas
plutôt loin d'ici ça reste dans les
yvelines je crois que c'est à limay mais
ne voulant remplacer ce système par une
cuisine centrale qu'elles soient
communales ou intercommunales
mais sur laquelle nous ayons directement
la main et nous puissions fournir aux
enfants des bons produits qu'ils soient
locaux et biologiques
et puis dernier une dernière proposition
que j'ai envie de poser ici et qui est
très importante sur cette transition
écologique
je voudrais qu'on puisse faire de
montigné la capitale du vélo s'agit pas
d'avoir un vélodrome
il s'agit pas de se contenter d'une note
c'est dans la récente enquête de l'ats
de la fédération de l'afub
c'est vrai que nos voisins font pas
forcément mieux on doit viser le à part
un véritable plan vélo qui porte sur les
pistes cyclables mais aussi l'entretien
des pistes cyclables les points noirs
pour la sécurité les stationnements tous
les services qui sont associés on doit
être très ambitieux sur ces questions du
vélo beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui
merci pierre déjean vous avez du retard
donc que vous pouvez allez-y sur votre
programme sur la transition
environnementale bien déjà premier point
nous ne parlons pas de transition mais
effectivement d'écologie parce que nous
allons nous ne voulons pas remettre les
choses au calendes grecques
et c'est tout de suite qu'il faut agir
il faut agir avec sur des grands sur des
grands axes avec des grandes ambitions
alors la rénovation effectivement des
locaux municipaux déjà on a eu un
exemple extraordinaire la mairie lors du
mandat précédent à rénover l'école marie
noëlle leur faisant du bon travail
et puis
il c'est arrivé à un moment donné où il
fallu s'occuper d'un autre scolaire et
de ce moment là j'étais dans réunions de
commissions je crois qu'il s'agissait de
jules verne et je regarde le projet qui
était quand même très en-deça ce qui
avait été fait et je dis qu'il faudrait
peut-être faire la même chose que pour
marie noëlle et là une adjointe qui
étaient présentes se dit ah mais
monsieur des gens on ne va quand même
pas faire pour toutes les écoles ce
qu'on a fait le gros marie noëlle et
bien justement si je pense que c'est ça
aussi l'égalité il fallait faire pour
toutes les écoles ce qui a été fait pour
marie noëlle c'est très bien il fallait
continuer parce que c'est aussi une
question écologique mais c'est aussi une
question de justice et d'égalité
alors nous avons aussi l'ambition de
développer les transports en commun
plutôt que les transports individuels la
visuel il ya des moments on peut pas
s'en passer certes mais les transports
en commun qui sont un facteur d'économie
d'énergie et nous allons dès notre
arrivée aux affaires entamé des
négociations pour rendre le réseau de
bus de saint quentin en yvelines gratuit
du âge c'est quelque chose qui se fait
dans beaucoup de communes ou
d'agglomération d'un homme dans tout le
pays et qu'ils rendent des résultats
extraordinaires car en plus de la
facilité qu'ont apporté bien on trouve
aussi une amélioration y compris qu'il
était tiff
c'est dire qu'il ya moins de
dégradations la cuisine centrale
effectivement quelque chose que nous
avons proposées et c'est une bonne idée
puisque vivien l'a repris sur notre site
c'est parfait et nous avons également en
projet d'intérêt
la reprise du raison d'un bout à l'autre
du traitement de l'eau qui aujourd'hui
privatisée et nous avons attention
effectivement de le petit à petit et
bien de le remettre en régime en régie
municipale
nous aurons aussi l'introduction de
l'âne ambition d'avoir l'introduction du
100 % bio dans les cantines avec du vrai
bio c'est à dire que non seulement par
la qualité des aliments mais également
par rapport aux circuits de transport et
de distribution
certes nous avons favorisé l'église et
les agriculture de proximité
vous avez beaucoup d'avant ce vraiment
20 secondes si vous souhaitez répondre à
un besoin
j'ai simplement remercié pierre déjean
et son équipe d'avoir participé à toutes
les assemblées ouvertes qui nous ont
permis de construire notre programme
merci laurent merckaert vous votre
programme sur la transition
environnementale alors sur ce sujet là
nous avons souhaité nous allons proposer
aux habitants dans le cadre du programme
que nous présenterons bientôt deux
aspects le premier porte sur le
fonctionnement interne propre à la
mairie et là dessus
en fait la personne qui sera si nous
sommes élus ont premier adjoint sera à
la fois en charge des finances et à la
fois responsable au sein de la
collectivité de la transition écologique
dans les modes de fonctionnement de la
mairie c'est à dire que chaque année au
moment de la discussion budgétaire
tous les services dans les propositions
qu'ils apporteront dans le
fonctionnement qu'ils auront devront
être challenge et sur cette thématique
là il existe aujourd'hui des
référentiels très intéressant qui
permettent à des collectivités
travail se fait à bordeaux et dans paris
de bien d'autres communes et donc nous
voulons nous appuyer là-dessus parce que
je pense que l'argent est le nerf de la
guerre si on veut agir efficacement pour
faire changer les choses il faut que
l'on fonctionne à ce niveau là le
deuxième aspect c'est de continuer de
développer ce que nous faisons depuis un
certain nombre d'années
monsieur gasquet évoqué la note c'est
que nous avons cette note c elle traduit
une troisième place pour montigny en
termes de politique pour l'accueil du
vélo une troisième place au niveau la
région ile de france est une quatrième
place au niveau national pour les villes
si si absolument monarque est donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
position où on voit bien qu
effectivement sur montigny nous avons 43
km au total de voies cyclables et donc
il ya eu des efforts très importants sur
simplement donc poursuivre des
initiatives avec les habitants comme ce
que nous avons travaillé avec le working
optait aussi pour associer les habitants
parce que c'est aussi en associant les
gens qu'on fait changer les modes de
comportement et puis je terminerais pour
un parent de poing qui concerne
l'agglomération avec laquelle nous
travaillons aussi beaucoup sur les
mobilités et je pense qu'effectivement
ça sera un des enjeux essentiels on va
bientôt avoir une navette autonome
électrique en expérimentation sur
montigny
ça sera une solution certainement pour
augmenter l'offre de transport sur la
voie mais on voit le temps de parole qui
vont s'afficher un beau coup de retard
pour pierre déjean divin gas vous avez à
peu près une minute de retard laurent
mais retard pour sept ans en avance on
va aborder un dernier thème alors on
devait aborder la solidarité la sécurité
vivre ensemble et la démocratie locale
mais je pense qu'il ya un sujet qui est
important ça va être la gestion de cette
période sur la compétition les jeux
olympiques que parce que le prochain
maire va accueillir les jeux olympiques
en 2024 notamment les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome et le
bmx à lille de loisirs ça va être un
moment spécial pour le maire qui va
devoir gérer l'affluence de plusieurs
millions de personnes
alors paris et puis en même temps sur
sur saint quentin en yvelines
comment vous allez gérer cette période
et je vous allez commencer pierre déjean
puisque vous avez un peu comme allure et
heureusement le maire de mont dit quel
qu'il soit
quels qu'ils soient ne sont ne sera pas
seul effectivement c'est toute une
organisation bien sûr et pouvant table
ce que je vais dire peut-être par contre
c'est que c'est un événement important
peut-être faut pas non plus lui donner
trop d'importance et on a l'exemple de
ce qu'il faut pas faire avec
avec le vélodrome qui nous a coûté très
cher et qui va coûter encore très cher
pendant un certain nombre d'années aux
impôts aux habitants et on a vous
parliez du bmx cet exemple qui est quand
même extraordinaire où on a une piste de
bmx aux normes olympiques et bac il
pourra pas sévère pour les olympiques
car n'est pas un nombre à pic et on va
en construire une autre à côté une
deuxième parce que justement il faut que
cette paix sont aux normes et qui va
payer
qui va payer et si ce n'est les
effectivement les habitants de saint
quentin de montigné de saint quentin et
puis les autres
donc c'est quelque chose dont il faut
pas perdre de vue
et si on regarde de par le monde tous
les sites olympiques qui ont été
construits exprès ou ça il y en a
beaucoup qui sont tombés en complète
décrypte les défauts d'entretien parce
que faute de crédits et je crois que de
ce côté là on n'est pas le parti
maintenant on va les jouer un pays
qu'ils auront lieu on les accueillera
bien entendu à bras ouverts et je
signale qu'il n'y a pas des jeux
olympiques mais deux jeux olympiques
puisque derrière il ya afin de revendre
les parts aux olympiques mais qui sont
aussi très importants vivien gasc sur ce
sujet je voudrais d'abord à titre
préalable pour savoir un peu si nous
sommes à armes égales sur ce sujet a
demandé alors un merckaert nous précise
son emploi actuel vous travaillez bien
sûr le sur les jeux olympiques
maintenant je crois monsieur n'ont
absolument pas d'accord j'étais mal du
coup votre propre répondra après
peut-être à la question sur ses genoux
mais pas dit ce que faisait comme
travail puisque je fais ça ne vous
regarde pas mais je ne travaille pas en
lien d'autres jeux olympiques
peut-être que ça regarde un petit peu
les regarde un tout petit peu lésigny
montant puisque vous nous avez expliqué
que vous étiez plus aujourd'hui en
charge du cabinet
montigny-le-bretonneux et vous prétendez
à partir du mois d'avril prochain à
notre fonction et donc on est intéressé
à savoir ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
vous revenir sur les pratiques comme de
2024 voulait pas nous dire c'est un
secret alors ce qui est important avec
ses jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est qu' il soit inclusif et solidaires
paris 2024 a signé une convention avec
le la société soli deo la société qui
réalise les ouvrages olympiques et
paralympiques avec les canaux un acteur
central de l'économie sociale et
solidaire est avec moi bagnoud douce
mohammad yunus
l'homme aux trois 0-0 pauvreté zéro
chômage zéro émission carbone
ce que nous voulons c'est que ces jeux
olympiques soit inclusif et solidaire
sur le territoire de l'agglomération
l'agglomération n'était pas présente à
cette signature n'est pas non plus dans
les premiers territoires directement
impactés par le par les jeux olympiques
par rapport à la seine saint denis par
exemple mais je pense qu'il faut
s'approprier ses objectifs pour que les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
puissent bénéficier de cette de cette
énorme élan pour le sur l'emploi et sur
la transition écologique
vous avez 30 secondes votre conclusion
et je voulais dire aussi que sur les sur
les épreuves de vélo en particulier on
va pas parler du vélodrome qui coûte
c'est effectivement 5 millions d'années
5 millions d'euros chaque année aux
contribuables mais qui est là donc il
faut faire de montils à la capitale du
vélo sur deux je pense qu'il faut lier
davantage la pratique de loisirs du vélo
par exemple à la grande compétition il
faut pas se contenter d'un d'une épreuve
d'un équipement phare et qu'il faut
beaucoup plus le général laurent
marquardt sur ce sujet oui alors sur les
jeux olympiques
évidemment c'est une chance
extraordinaire de pouvoir les accueillir
sur montigny le bretonneux
mais sur un sujet comme ça simplement se
réjouir de l'événement qui aura lieu
dans quatre ans c'est un peu court
est ce que nous souhaitons nous c'est
faire vivre ces jeux olympiques sur la
ville tout pendant tout pendant les
quatre années qui l'ont précédé on
souhaite pour cela associé les habitants
associer les associations l'éducation
nationale pour faire un appel à idées
sur tout ce qui pourrait être proposé
dans ce cadre là
on sait que dans le sport il ya aussi un
côté social très forte puisque on peut
inclure des enfants faire participer des
enfants leur faire découvrir des
activités sportives
n'oublions pas non plus que les jeux
olympiques au départ était à la fois
sportif et culturel donc on peut aussi
jouer sur cet aspect là des choses et
essayer de fédérer un maximum
d'habitants autour de ce sujet voilà
merci on arrive au terme de cette
émission la conclusion pour chacun on va
prendre l'ordre inverse de la prise de
la première prise de parole on va
commencer avec vous vivez avec gas vous
avez une minute un merci alors par le
travail collectif et surtout public que
nous avons engagé l'année dernière pour
construire notre programme nous nous
sommes placés au coeur de cette campagne
nos concurrents et je pense
principalement aux candidats qui va être
investi par la droite départementale
court après nos idées cherche plus à
s'inspirer de nous qu'à innover
nous avons déjà gagné la bataille des
idées maintenant ce qui nous importe
c'est de continuer de convaincre qu'un
changement de cap est souhaitable
nous avons à la fois la lucidité de
vouloir garder ce qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui et les compétences pour
mettre en oeuvre les propositions fortes
que nous avons sont jeudi à chaque
réunion j'éprouve un réel plaisir à
travailler avec cette équipe très
dynamique très dynamique et dans
laquelle les femmes jouent un rôle de
premier plan
lorsque sony atc par exemple proposer
des présente ses propositions en matière
de démocratie participative lors de nos
réunions
c'est qu'elles portent tout ce pan du
programme et qu elle en organise la
diffusion
lorsque vous inviter m lors de votre jt
c'est karolinska aux nomes mon binôme en
tête de liste qui vient présenter nos
propositions conclure et plus
généralement leur nos réunions publiques
ce sont 10 15 personnes qui sont là pour
détailler nos priorités je voulais juste
te dire que c'est pas comme ça j'ai
choisi son passé nazi comme on a pu le
voir la même session sinon c'est pas
égalitaire merci du zinc à bercy elle
aura merckaert pareil même contrainte
une minute pour conclure s'il vous plaît
donc aujourd'hui je souhaite mettre mon
expérience de dix neuf années au service
de la ville et désigne montain dans le
pour cette pour cette prochaine élection
je me suis entouré d'une équipe comme je
les dis renouvelée rajeunie avec des
membres des associations des conseils de
quartier des gens très impliqué nous
avons des retours extrêmement positif et
favorable de la part de la population
depuis le début de la campagne des gens
qui depuis la soirée à la salle jacques
brel ou ou la salle était complète et
encore la semaine dernière pendant le
tractage des gens qui nous place dans
une très grande dynamique très forte par
rapport à cette élection et ça c'est un
vrai bonheur merci pierre déjean vous
avez deux minutes pour conclure si vous
souhaitez les utiliser oui bah bah
écoutez je crois qu'à l'issue de ce
débat court trop court mais je comprends
les contraintes dont en particulier
peuvent aborder le nid le thème de l'est
du scolaire knees le talent de culture
qui sont des actes importants chez nous
nous avons en fait trois listes une
liste menée par julien gasc dont on a un
peu de mal à saisir la cohérence parce
que eux mêmes ont du mal à se situer et
dans les positions varient au gré des
interviews il ya qu à regarder ce qui
est écrit dans la presse pour se rendre
compte
ni gauche ni droite on sait ce que ça
donne et nous en national donc on va pas
essayer de ne pas renouveler la même
chose au niveau local nous aurons à
l'est de conduite par monsieur mertert
qui elle se situe à droite centre droite
c'est assumer ses traits c'est très bien
et dont la famille politique se transmet
la mairie de père en fils enfin c'est
une image bien entendu en fête de mères
en demeurant directeur de cabinet donc
et je crois qu'il est temps de mettre
fin à cette poésie dynastie et puis nous
avons la laisse la nôtre montigny
solidarité 2020 que j'ai l'honneur et le
plaisir de conduire c'est une liste de
rassemblement de citoyens aux valeurs
fortes motivé engagé compétente
expérimentée dans plusieurs domaines et
nous sommes prêts à assumer nos
responsabilités
merci on a quelques écarts mais on
rééquilibrera ces temps de parole d'ici
la fin de la campagne
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat sur notre antenne et sur
radio sensations à revoir sur notre site
internet sur l'application mobile
en attendant la campagne va se
poursuivre
les inimitables peuvent consulter vos
programmes vos réunions sur notre site
internet
on fera aussi des reportages pour
poursuivre cette campagne jusqu'au 15
mars
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]